alors Véronique comment ça va bien et
vous-même monsieur
on est ravi de vous accueillir comme
chaque semaine et aujourd'hui on va
commencer avec une information sur un
bar russe ukrainien avec
un concept complètement étonnant en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que je suis pas si
un jour dans ce lieu qui est tout près
de la cathédrale Saint-Louis à
Versailles sur un tout petit un tout
petit restaurant mais vraiment même pas
le mot restaurant enfin et il proposait
des des raviolis russes Ukrainiens la
serveuse était ruse par les Français je
suis quand même incroyable ce truc et
donc en fait ils ont une première
adresse à Paris c'est un restaurant
entre enfin déjà bien installé ils sont
rue du Richer à Paris et j'ai appelé
donc la personne qui a l'initiative de
ce projet alors elle s'appelle Elena big
timeirova et son histoire c'est qu'elle
est demeureuse et de père ukrainien son
frère actuellement est à la guerre en
Ukraine et elle me dit mais moi j'aime
les deux peuples c'est c'est double
souffrance en fait cette guerre pour les
personnes qui peuvent qui ont des Data
famille dans les deux pays c'est juste
atroce et elle elle était en France
depuis 5 ans elle a fait une école de
cuisine qui s'appelle le cordon bleu
elle a travaillé dans différents
restaurants et elle s'est décidé juste
au début de la guerre à monter ce
pyroche qui barre je sais pas si je
prononce comme il faut ou elle propose
de la nourriture à la fois russe et
Ukraine on utilise les mêmes ingrédients
il y a très peu de différence elle elle
propose les recettes de sa grand-mère
russe et le personnel est soit russe
soit ukrainien il y a des réfugiés qui
sont là qui parle pas encore français
mais ça va venir et donc elle a aussi ce
petit lieu à Versailles qui est un peu
en devenir où on peut déjà entre 11h et
15h aller chercher à emporter donc ces
fameux raviolis soit russe soit
ukrainien et toute cette cuisine alors
soit on la connaît déjà et on va être
ravie de la retrouver parce que là c'est
vraiment on est dans l'authentique à
100% soit on a envie de découvrir des
choses vraiment différentes et là pour
le coup c'est le cas alors si vous
voulez que je vous explique si vous êtes
un petit peu pointu ma chère amie je
peux vous dire que vous allez trouver
là-bas des accouski bien sûr des pelles
mélisses qui sont des raviolis russes
des Varennes liquides raviolis
Ukrainiens un dessert qui s'appelle le
Medovic enfin on est vraiment dans le
pur tradition enfin des choses qu'on
connaît pas qui sont absolument
délicieuses et après bien cette ce petit
lieu à Versailles va évoluer va devenir
aussi donc vente à emporter tout est
fait maison et il va devenir aussi une
boutique avec des produits qu'on trouve
nulle part et voilà on en reparlera mais
en tout cas du fait maison à emporter
c'est génial ça donne envie c'est un
vrai dépaysement comme je vous avais
parlé daisuki restaurant japonais c'est
exactement ça c'est de la nourriture
locale de là-bas qui est transporté ici
par ce savoir-faire d'Elena voilà et ben
merci on va continuer à parler de
cuisine à Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse un
tiers-lieux propose un menu
bistronomique exactement alors justement
il y a un lien avec vous et si je peux
me permettre de dire vous avez dit un
lieu dit là où se trouve le le concert
du samedi c'est pas un lieu-dit c'est un
tiers-lieux voilà mais ça permet de
rebondir et du coup quand vous parliez
de restauration de goûter on peut c'est
un bistrot qui a un bistronomie donc
c'est vraiment qualitatif qui fait aussi
salon de thé donc on peut aussi voir
votre public pourra aussi s'il restaurer
bien qui s'y récemment
pour les téléspectateurs
qui a été inventé il y a pas très
longtemps par des jeunes chefs c'est ces
bistrot donc c'est un côté assez rapide
et pas trop élaboré qu'on vivait voilà
mais avec des produits très haute
qualité et au final des quelque chose de
délicieux et le chef qui qui est donc ça
s'appelle chez Lili on va finir par par
parler du projet donc chez Lily propose
donc la restauration à l'heure du
déjeuner ou salon de l'après-midi vous
pouvez aussi c'est un traiteur vous
pouvez commander pour des événements et
aussi commander pour des choses à
emporter alors derrière ça ce lieu il
est donc rue de Coubertin à
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse
avenue pardon bienvenue
c'est très très bon ben voilà il faut
vraiment y aller et donc pourquoi ils
ont créé ce lieu parce qu'à la base
c'est un projet social c'est c'est pas
une association c'est une sic qu'est-ce
que c'est qu'une sic une coopérative
d'intérêt collectif voilà un modèle
d'entreprise à but non lucratif et c'est
constance qui a qui a voulu monter un
projet social avec la création de
soutien il est en devenir aussi se tient
le glace sont dans les deux premières
étapes et comme son projet a besoin de
financement et qu'elle voulait être il
voulait être autonome ils sont plusieurs
bénévoles mais c'est leur façon de
gagner de l'argent et d'être autonome
pour après toutes les toutes les choses
qui vont proposer donc ça concerne à la
base des personnes qui ont subi
l'inceste alors pas très c'est voilà
mais bon et c'est un sujet assez c'est
particulier dans la scène parce que
autant les victimes que les
professionnels ont du mal à a parlé
c'est un peu stigmatisé ça fait peur et
il faut quand même savoir que 10% de la
population française a subi ou enfin
subi de l'inceste donc c'est quand même
malheureusement très répandu et donc
leur idée assez à ces gens de force de
vivre c'est de proposer un lieu parce
que l'inceste en fait c'est un abus de
pouvoir par le lien
familial on
la hiérarchie fait que on impose à
l'enfant par le lien voilà donc le lien
il est le lien même aux autres du coup
c'est clair il est abîmé il faut le
restaurer et donc l'idée c'est de
trouver un lieu apaisé ou des gens qui
ont subi l'inceste qui sont en parcours
de résilience et des gens qui n'ont rien
à voir avec ça soit mélanger pour
restaurer cette ouverture au monde et
que les gens se mélangent les
différences se mélangent etc donc après
en septembre on reparlera aussi j'espère
il y aura des conférences des ateliers
plein de choses et on pas du tout enfin
quand vous êtes dans ce lieu il y a pas
écrit à balle inceste enfin bref c'est
c'est un lieu un peu hors du temps je
trouve ça c'est une ambiance très beau
jardin voilà c'est serein c'est apaisant
et on peut y aller qu'on est ce problème
de ou pas on peut y aller juste pour se
détendre et l'idée c'est que les gens se
mélangent et des projets communs avec
aussi ce à quoi ils tiennent c'est il y
a pas de hiérarchie justement ce espèce
de pouvoir de la hiérarchie chacun fait
son travail chacun sa page chacun à sa
voix et qu'est-ce que je pourrais avoir
oublié de vous dire ou bien justement
que vous vouliez nous parler également
de vos derniers VIP avec Julie Andrieu
et avec Alain barrette je voulais dire
qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié de vous dire
sur ce sur ce sérieux et bah en fait non
j'ai rien oublié donc c'est nickel vous
avez raison on enchaîne on enchaîne
alors le prochain film en fait il y en a
un que j'ai tourné avec Julie Andrieu à
Versailles car elle est de là et euh et
je vais en tournée alors je lui ai
andriol elle a sorti un livre qui
s'appelle pasta ce sont ces recettes de
pâtes alors des recettes qu'on connaît
et après j'ai découvert ça c'est aussi
des recettes qu'elle a créé elle-même et
qui sont à découvrir voilà c'est un
choix de livre et donc ben on l'a reçu
et c'est sur les c'est en train d'être
diffusé chez vous chez nous ici voilà et
demain j'aurai Alain Barathon pareil
dans son jardin pour son livre sur la
rose et vous nous entendez sans doute la
semaine prochaine mais super merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup Véronique comme
chaque semaine de nous présenter vos
insolites